I'm Marcellus Carmi and this is for
estefany third grade who made me a card
elephant on an orange line underneath a
yellow circle meaning Sun six green
vertical lines with color all from the
top meaning flowers the first time I
peel back the five squares of scotch
tape unfold the crooked crease fold of
art class paper I am in my living room
it is June inside of the card
there is one long word and then a
Stephanie's named Lois hurry worry s
Stephanie Louis Ferrari Louis February
the scientific Latin it way of saying
hibiscus lows February a direction as in
are you going north south east west
Louis Rory I try over and over to read
the word out loud those furry hello ease
worry worry
Louis furry Barry Louis very worried
what is this word I imagine using it in
sentences like man I have to go back to
the house I forgot my Louis for owari or
there's nothing better than rain hot
rain open windows with music and a tall
glass of Louis Ferrari or how are we
getting to Pittsburgh should we drive or
take the lowest for everywhere I have
lived four minutes with this word not
knowing what it means
it is the end of the year I consider
writing my student as Stephanie a letter
that goes to the brilliant Stephanie Ola
get ela I hope that you are well I've
just opened the card that you made me
and it is beautiful I really love the
way you filled the sky with birds
I believe that you are Chula - Lita and
super fly yes the card is beautiful I
only have one question for you
what does the word Lois for air I mean I
try it the word again
Lois very worried it was very very nice
very very I try the word in Spanish nor
sweaty ready
Lois very body very sweaty body and then
slowly lo piece for B body law is for
anybody
love is for everybody love is for every
everybody love love love everybody love
everybody love love is love everybody
everybody is love love love for love for
everybody for love is everybody love is
for every love is for everybody
love love love for body love body body
is love love is body everybody is love
is every love for every love is love for
love everybody loved love loved love for
everybody love is for every body for an
interview with the poet watch this video
or check out the next poem in this
series